[Musique]
ce sont toujours des images saisissantes
en mission accomplie pour l' agence
spatiale canadienne les trois sets et
lettres de la mission qu'on appelle
constellation radarsat tu sont
maintenant en route pour leur
destination finale vont autour de la
terre ils vont transmettre au canada des
données essentielles sur notre
environnement et je jouais justement
steevy risque gestionnaire de mission à
l'agencé spatiale canadienne alors
d'abord monsieur et riffs tout s'est
bien passé le décollage s'est effectuée
à 10h17 heure précise il y avait quand
même un faible risque d'échec en de
lancement oui est toujours un risque
pour des lancements de fusées
sur le risque qui toute façon chacun
sait qu'en ce moment là où il y en avait
un mais comme vous avez mentionné c'est
super bien déroulé comme prévu jusqu'à
maintenant donc on attend la suite le
dans quelques minutes
on sait que l agence a quand même
collaboré donc vous sentez comment ce
point si vous êtes content on est très
heureux pour l'ensemble de l'équipe non
seulement l'équipe du bournat même
également toute l'équipe de l'industrie
qui travaillent très fort au cours de
l'année pour cette réalisation là et
puis là-bas surtout lancement perso ça
vaut vraiment être la mise en service du
satellite pour qu'on allait les données
conservées vraiment
à chacun des ministres pour le biais de
services au canada exactement si on
revient sur cette mission elle a même
plusieurs années de retard et fallait
vraiment que les satellites soit lancée
aujourd'hui pouvez vous nous expliquer
pour quelles raisons en fait comme la
construction de la sarthe et la
troisième génération donc elle prend le
relais de rabat 7 2 a lancé redoutent
toujours une opération va continuer de
l'être jusqu'à temps qu'ils aient des
signes de défaillance plus près plus
annoncé
le rotor vient du fait que l'annoncé
initiale en 2004 du
leur travail est que les ministères sur
dans la phase de design pour améliorer
le système punir on me répond mieux à
leurs besoins donc au fur et à mesure
qu'ils avaient des nouveautés des
éléments considérés on les a ajouté
exemple le système d'identification
automatique n'était pas initialement
prévu a été ajoutée mais chacune des
fois on a fait des analyses de coûts
bénéfices pour démontrer cet avantage là
et figurer à la fin que le savez d'être
coup de l'ajouter pour avoir une mission
plus efficace et opérationnel à la faute
on rappelle que ces trois sets elle est
là vont à les remplacer si je comprends
bien radarsat 2 qui est vraiment rendu à
la fin de sa vie utile
est-ce qu'il est toujours opérationnel
est-ce qu'il fonctionne bien il est
toujours d'être opérationnel fonctionne
très bien c'est sûr que quand on a des
données comme cette utilisation
opérationnelle on essaie de pas avoir de
trou dans les couvertures ou dans les
disparités des données donc c'est le cas
présentement donc on lance une nouvelle
génération ralenti à 2 n'appartient pas
au gouvernement du canada est une
propriété d'une entreprise privée qui
est un des grands groupes de mac sort
donc le vent continue d'opérer de façon
commerciale de gravats consignes
d'utiliser en partie mais ce que nous
nageons serait déjà question maintenant
est transféré sur la consommation
d'alsace
alors expliquez nous pour les gens qui
connaissent très peu ce domaine là ils
sont quand même plusieurs à quoi ils
vont servir précisément à parler aux
oraux gens qui nous écoutent
qu'est-ce qui vous permettre de récolter
comme données
donc c'est des images de notre planète
c'est différent par exemple de ce que
des gens voient par exemple google et
des images qui sont similaires à ce
qu'on prépare avec une caméra standard
ou un téléphone dans notre cas c'est une
onde qui est émise et qui rebondit au
sol qui est revient cette information au
loup est converti en images j'ai parlé
ce qu'on peut s'en sort et pour
différentes applications exemple les
grandes caractéristiques des glaces de
mer on peut cartographier seraient
ensuite envoyées sur directement aux
navires qui navigue dans les eaux pour
transporter leurs marchandises ça nous
permet de l'identifier clairement le
chemin le plus court le point pour david
et on peut également s'en servir pour
l'agriculture donc beaucoup
d'informations sur les types de cultures
la croissance des cultures
ça nous aide à mieux prévoir à la
récolte et améliorer aussi la
distribution soit de fertilisants d'eau
dans les champs donc à la fin le
consommateur us aux oufs du tout parce
que ça coûte moins cher à produire
certains aliments les données les
marchandises coûte moins cher est ivre
également des données aussi sur les
inondations comme on en a connu dans les
dernières semaines
oui c'est un parfait exemple donc ce qui
s'est passé récemment au québec en
ontario au nouveau-brunswick et beaucoup
de données de radars 7,2 donc des
données similaires pourraient être
prises par la conservation à la recette
qui ont été fournis donc nos collègues
de ressources naturelles canada ont
produit de nombreuses cartes
d'inondations que vous rendez les
montrer
où la limite des inondations ou les
secteurs qui étaient affectés
donc ça va être les équipes de secours
au sol a été redonné plus rapidement et
efficacement par le souffre exactement
filles en terminant quand est ce qu'elle
est faite et les deux vont entrer en
fonction je ne sais pas s'ils sont
rendus non lors la prochaine étape ça va
être de déploiement de chacun sait si
c'était d'être là à partir du
distributeur spéciale qui étaient conçus
on va voir ça dans quelques minutes et
par la suite on entrevoit une période
d'au moins trois mois de mise en service
donc toute la mise en service de chacun
des instruments l'allumage la
calibration de titre heavy mode image
extérieure dont nantes rouen - devraient
commencer à recevoir nous données
opérationnelles pour le gouvernement
j'espère m'assurer de bien comprendre la
mise en service prend trois mois oui
parce que c'est assez complexe
une fois que on à coursan jouent à peu
près que cette élite a atteint son
orbite définitive
ensuite faut ouvrir le panneau solaire
durant cette période là l'antenne radar
qui est en dessous de 30 les images
ouvrez chacun des instruments après
l'autre et on s'assoit chaque fois
qu'ils en a pas un qui peut causer un
problème donc on vérifie que c'est à
l'intérieur des limites le pays sont
prévues les images comme ça et comme
c'est un radar on doit calibré chacun
des modes d'acquisition le c'est
vraiment particulier
ça ça prend un certain temps donc on
devra s'assurer que les données sont
optimales pour être libre et au
ministère absolument steve iris
gestionnaire de missions à l'agent
spatiale canadienne merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous